yeah that's explain to the people what
you're talking about
i'm so bitter and it's it's fine because
to to be fair tim has been streaming
forever and i'm not really that angry
about it
but it is very a very ridiculous thing
so tin tatman ninja's
ninja's number one guardian angel this
is ninja's bro
he uh was playing this new game fall
guys which if you haven't played it
it's like um it's like a leapfrog game
on the computer
and um you played it last night
yeah so much fun so frustrating yeah
yeah no it's definitely it's definitely
entertaining
um yeah i'm not hating on the game at
all so tim is frustrated because he had
like
646 games and he hadn't won a single one
which to be fair i could see how you
could uh go that far
and lose um i can't relate because i
have just
you know procured a crown myself just
want to make that clear i have one once
okay and as a winner you know i'm
speaking from experience
that it's not that bad but no really so
he set out to stream yesterday
to win and um he finally did
and someone gifted like a thousand subs
or something it just like it just the
whole
thing went off the rails like his sub
count number was just
like a um it was like a lottery [ __ ]
counter like it just kept going up up up
up up i think he picked up like 10
000 subs in that one sitting
or like no but didn't sam say that one
person donated a [ __ ] ton
yeah sam said someone donated 8 000 subs
but that didn't seem right
or maybe that maybe that's what happened
i don't know
but um so how many subs did he pick up
in total
easily ten thousand ten thousand subs so
he made
30k no dude if you if you conservatively
average
each sub is five bucks right and some of
them might have been
more someone could have been 10 or 15
and someone could have did tier
threes like you just don't know so so he
yeah it's like 50k yeah 50k
jesus christ can you imagine beating
fall guys
after just a couple hours of playing
casually and then you get 50
000
holy [ __ ] it took me
i don't know how long to get even
to where i'm at and this dude did it
in seven hours i'm like that's so wild
that that that happens now
yeah someone donated a thousand subs to
a [ __ ]
millionaire just because
that's how much he likes his content oh
wait let me be very clear i'm not
i'm not bitter i'm not that bitter about
it because i know someone's going to be
like you just sound
jealous i'm not because no but that's no
but i'm listen i'm happy to admit that
when i read this article about ryan
reynolds
i am [ __ ] envious and i'm jealous
and i'm bitter because i'm a bad person
because i all i feel is envy
selling a [ __ ] liquor company for 610
million dollars yeah dude
oh yeah yeah and being super hot and
funny
i'm [ __ ] jealous he hit the you know
what i'm saying
you want to [ __ ] ryan reynolds i don't
want i want to
i want to voodoo him do you want to
voodoo him i want to take voodoo and
jerk myself off
you put on a vr headset and you get to
voodoo ryan reynolds that's gonna be
cameo in 2030.
all right i'm doing voodoos all day
today um
a hundred dollars a minute that's only
fans
yeah and and yeah basically
but only fans is you know still in the
primitive state where you have to
manually request to that person hey yeah
do this to yourself in the future it'll
be straight up voodooing it'll be you
know
oh you know that you know when guys were
like dude what would you do if you had a
pair of breasts for a day well you'll
get to voodoo
and find out exactly what you would do
if you had a sick pair of
bazingas that'll probably happen
honestly with vr
like oh yeah you already have you
already have flesh lights that are
molded after
porn stars yeah and dildos yeah both of
them
yeah why wouldn't you be able to plug
into vr and either
like be that person
or [ __ ] them sorry i just have to
tangent for just a quick second
because [ __ ] i don't want to
uh yeah you know what yeah frost
from the mob [ __ ] you man for that [ __ ]
you retweeted last night
[ __ ] you i'm on twitter minding my
[ __ ] business
this boy frost retweets a dude doing
dumbbell curls
with his dick out and [ __ ] you twitter
for auto playing video
cause i'm scrolling and all i see as i'm
scrolling is a dude
hitting the top of the rep and his
[ __ ] boner coming up with it and then
dropping it back down i'm like what the
[ __ ] is this
that's funny no it was hilarious
that's straight up funny was he curling
with his boner yeah
like get a little weight on it uh nah it
was just it was just
you know it was bo it was a bodyweight
workout for the dick
his little chin up the dick
dick ups that's what it is it was dick
it was a it was a clean dick up
yeah well i'm repping dick ups today at
the gym what are you what are you doing
at the gym today chest nah i'm doing
dick
doing dick yeah yeah oh
dick like you're gonna hook up with
something no no i'm just working on my
dick
yeah heavy dick wraps today yeah
yeah i gotta shock my body you know uh
we're doing uh doing lightweight
a lot of reps you know gains aren't
really coming through on the dick so you
know it's got to switch it up
uh anyway um i'm kidding by the way i'm
not envious i'm a little bit envious i'm
a little bit envious
i'm a little bit jealous yeah how could
you not be no yeah that's human
you know look i don't know ryan reynolds
i can't be like oh he's my friend i'm
just happy for him right
yeah because in this time in this case
you know it kind of is a zero-sum game
you know dude there's not that many
liquor companies that can sell you know
dude just speaking of like vr ar
whatever
you know how people will you know i've
heard stories of people bailing on a
tinder date because they match with
someone else that they like better
like in the area or something right yeah
i'm just picturing how much easier
that's going to be with like ar
goggles like when when google releases
their ray-ban partnered ar
goggles and you're just doing with
someone on a date like oh yeah yeah yeah
and they just slowly lift up their
sunglasses and you're like what are you
doing
like oh no i'm just you know the sun in
my face
and then they just get a dm as they're
as you're trying to talk to them they're
like ah
yeah they're like all right
well hey man it was nice that you're
doing it to me no i'm not doing that
you're doing numb i don't know i'm just
i'm just gonna go i'm just gonna get out
of here
it's nice to meet you see you later
one and done oh no i thought you i think
you're going to say they just changed
the person at the table
to be the other person yeah like just to
look like them because nothing's real
like oh
well if you have ar goggles they could
just do a little like
a little snapchat animation of the other
person just
dancing on the table
i thought you were saying like re-skin
the other person
i was saying that but it would be funny
if it was just like a shittier version
like a little bonsai buddy
yeah those who you really want to see
dancing on the table just to like keep
you at bay
while you're on a bad date oh my god
[Laughter]
dude
you